[Musique]
bonjour à tous l'invité de soccer 10 ce
matin karine rousseau bonjour bonjour
bonjour la martinique vous êtes
conseiller territorial présidente du
comité martiniquais du tourisme ce
critère territorial des républicains de
martinique est candidate à la députation
dans la circonscription du centre
atlantique que s'est il passé 15 ans ou
le samedi vous annoncez gabriel la grand
qu'au candidat dans le sud est comme
suppliante silva sa soutane et le lundi
rebondissements c'est la verse
s'il versailles soutane et candidates
galles braila gondecourt suppléant eh
bien écoutez
il s'est passé que vous savez que les
décisions au niveau des républicains
sont prises en bureau et que nous devons
investir des candidats dans chaque
circonscription que gabriel la grand
court avait donc donné sa candidature
nous avons donc statuer sur la
candidature de gabriella grands courants
tant que parti les républiques
maintenant la droite et le centre c'est
une grande famille une famille unie en
tout cas nous avons montré que nous nous
sommes uniques nous sommes au combat et
que nous sommes là pour gagner
c'est vrai que sylvia saïss houten je
dirais réfléchissait à sa décision
puisque elle avait dit qu'elle voulait
être suppléant de gabriel donc
évidemment être au combat sur cette
circonscription
le positionnement de sylvia sa soutane
fait que on lui a dit on a beaucoup
discuté ensemble que évidemment le duo
gagnant entre guillemets serait celui où
elle serait elle en position de
candidate et gabriel à grand couronne en
suppléant
on a de plus alors de gros crois qu
alors non non non non c'est pas du tout
en quoi que c'est vrai qu'il fallait
laisser à sylvia le temps de la
réflexion
sachant que de toute façon le poste de
suppléant est un poste important qu'il
revient à gabriella grand court et je
crois que ce qui est important c'est que
finalement c'est un duo qui va aux
élections
sylvia aujourd'hui est candidate sur le
sud ce qui nous réjouit évidemment pour
notre famille politique sachant son
positionnement son travail son sérieux
et puis voilà l'ats silvia saïd soutane
que nous connaissons donc il n'y a aucun
couac d'autant plus que les deux
protagonistes sont tout à fait d'accord
gabriela grand cour accepte évidemment
d'être le suppléant de sylvia sa soutane
et c'est vrai qu'il lui fallait a elle
aussi le temps de la réflexion
quand vous annoncez samedi
gabriel la grand court sur les réseaux
sociaux la candidature de sylvie la cei
soutane est annoncée dont elle savait
déjà qu'elle voulait y aller
allez être candidat de qualité dit
jacques candidate oui mais moi ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que pour nous
candidat ou suppléants l'essentiel c'est
ce duo que forment les deux
il a fait de ce tueur sur la alors il
est vrai que ça s'est pas fait en un
claquement de doigts il a fallu bien
discuter nous avons discuté sur avec eux
deux et c'est surtout à eux deux qui ont
discuté ce c'est surtout eux deux qui
ont eu à discuter justement pour savoir
finalement quel était le positionnement
qui qui nous donne le plus de chances de
gagner et je suis sûr que dans le sud
nous sortirons gagnants qui a voulu
aller plus vite que la musique
eh bien écoutez vous savez que dans les
partis il ya des ddd date butoir entre
guillemets pour donner des investitures
mais quoi qu'il en soit l'investiture
est donné à gabriel la grand court en
tant que suppléant qui est son
investiture est donné par le parti
républicain mais encore une fois ce qui
est important pour nous c'est que sylvia
sai soutane soit candidate dans le sud
et que c'est sûr nous sortirons gagnants
de cette élève certaines personnes au
sein de des républicains ont voulu
évincer six jeunes n'ont absolument pas
je vous répète que nous sommes une
famille unie au combat et que
l'important c'est que nous choisissions
de m non c'est pas la méthode coué vous
me connaissez pour ça
l'important c'est que nous choisissions
voilà les les positionnements qui vont
nous permettre de remporter ces
élections et je crois que c'est cette
décision que kiki est la meilleure et
est entérinée par tous on met au début
quand même
ce sera ma dernière question sur ce
point il ya une analyse et une stratégie
c'était pas l'évidence que ce soit
sylvia sa soutane
mais non ce oui évidemment que que nous
étions tous pour cette candidature
comment ne pas l'être quand on connaît
le travail de sylvia et son
positionnement
maintenant il lui fallait à l temps de
la réflexion aussi c'est ce que nous
avons attendu alors c'est vrai que
peut-être que ça c'est un petit peu
chevauchée parce que nous nous étions en
meetings politiques pour les
républicains donc notre parti mais quoi
qu'il en soit je pense que nous prenons
la bonne décision
eux aussi sylvia saïd soutane et
gabriela grand court que je remercie
d'ailleurs d'avoir accepté et bois pour
nous aller pour la victoire
vous êtes des candidats rassurez moi
dans le sens pas classique je suis bien
candidate dans le centre atlantique with
ovi supplie un suppléant alors je n'ai
pas encore choisi mon suppléant mais on
est en réflexion et puis maintenant nous
nous méfions nous préférons attendre le
fait qu'elle fait de mal j'ai ne se
représente pas sur la circonscription
est ce que ça rend les jus ce que du jus
plus ouverts bien écouter alfred
marie-jeanne on le connaît pour pour son
aura on le connaît pour cette trace
qu'il laisse dans l'histoire politique
de la martinique pour son travail aussi
actuellement c'est quelqu'un avec qui je
travaille beaucoup évidemment et pour
qui j'ai le plus grand respect
d'ailleurs qu'il ne se représente pas
sur cette circonscription five est
effectivement que les jeux sont ouverts
et que moi je pense que sur cette
circonscription tout peut arriver
il n'y a pas de circonscription facile
comme je voulais dit l'autre fois tout
peut arriver et
voilà que le meilleur gagne celui qui
arrivera à convaincre les électeurs
ces salles importe comment vous allez
faire car nous sauf face au candidat
soutenu par le mime dans la
circonscription
vous êtes quand même lié à la ctm
critiqué la position du mime sera
difficile à lyon bien écouter on a pas
du tout de problème là-dessus puisque je
vous rappelle que pour la collectivité
territoriale yan monplaisir et alfred
marie-jeanne en signer un contrat de
gestion
il s'agit de gérer cette collectivité
territoriale ensemble sur des valeurs
communes que nous avons le travail la
défense de l'entreprise et je crois que
nous le faisons bien nous le faisons
bien chacun notre place maintenant ces
élections législatives sont totalement
différente ce sont des élections
nationales qui sont surtout finalement d
élection de parti politique et c'est
très important ce sont des élections qui
évidemment sont liées aussi aux
présidentielles et je crois que sur ces
élections là chacun va défendre
finalement ces valeurs les valeurs de sa
famille politique
et c'est vrai que nous ne sommes pas
indépendantiste nous sommes en tout cas
moi républicaine et
la commission la famille de la droite et
du centre va défendre ses valeurs lui re
pacte de non agression un pacte de non
agression de toute façon on n'a pas
besoin d'en avoir puisque je crois qu'en
politique
nous sommes dans dans des élections et
pas dans un combat unis dans un pit quoi
agacer mais ce que je veux je veux
préciser c'est que ce sont vraiment des
élections nationales et que le député
n'a pas de mandat impératif il n'est pas
le député d'une circonscription il est
le député de toute la martinique et il
est aussi le député de tous les français
donc ce sont des élections totalement
différente et je crois que nous en tout
cas la famille de la droite et du centre
nous avons pour ces élections là notre
carte à jouer nos valeurs à défendre
notre ligne politique à défendre et nous
le ferons
alors cette inscription regroupe dix
communes de trinité roman de lamentin
françois et robert pas vraiment des
communes où la droite fait des scores
importants et bien écoutez
l'avenir nous le dira et puis notre
notre notre but est évidemment de
rassembler nous sommes une grande
famille la droite et le centre et je
crois que les dernières élections ont
montré que nous avons des électeurs ils
sont là et de plus en plus nombreux et
je pense que notre travail à la
collectivité territoriale il ya de
montplaisir sylvia saïd soutane dyade
montrose marinette torpille miguel
laventure prouve que les martiniquais
peuvent faire confiance à la droite
martiniquaise qui est en train
aujourd'hui je dirais de se relever
donc vous comptez vous effectivement
vous servir de l'alliance avec le grand
ensemble et du travail effectué à la
city m pour cela un désert c'est pas
s'en servir moi je dis que cette
élection que nous avons gagné avec le
mime
nous avons gagné ensemble nous a permis
à nous de prouver aux martiniquais que
dans nos troupes
eh bien il ya des gens compétents et
qu'on peut faire confiance à ces
personnes là et c'est ça qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est que les
martiniquais et les martiniquaises
comprennent qu'aujourd'hui on peut faire
confiance à la droite et au centre
martin qui donc c'est une façon aussi de
de savoir ce que l'on pèse dans le jeu
politique
ces pages on va pas là pour savoir ce
qu'on pèse nous y allons nous famille de
droite de la droite et du centre dans
chaque circonscription pour gagner et
pour faire valoir notre ligne politique
nos valeurs et puis tout ce que nous
avons à donner à la martinique dernière
question il manque quand même aux
candidats il ya le montplaisir qui dit
encore attendue n'est toujours pas prêt
yan monplaisir a peur de nos lecteurs à
0 je pense qu'il ya de montplaisir on le
connaît il n'a peur de rien et bien on
vous en saurez plus n'ont pas longtemps
je traque s'il sera candidat
eh bien écoutez il va venir ici vous
dire s'il est candidat ou pas mais je
suis confiant pour l'avenir en cas une
sauce je vous remercie sans que des
termes des bonis merci au programme à
très bientôt merci